salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
si je vous dis synonyme homonyme règle
de trois circulations sanguines
démographiques évidemment ça vous parle
mais quand il s'agit de développer un
peu de donner des chiffres des noms
alors là ça coince un peu et pourtant ce
sont des notions que nous avons acquises
au collège il y a quelques semaines nous
sommes revenus ensemble sur différents
éléments du programme de 6e visiblement
la vidéo vous a plu alors on continue
mais cette fois on retourne en 5e
Jamie au tableau
coucou on va commencer par les maths la
règle de trois ça vous parle alors c'est
une règle très simple dont on se sert
tous les jours sans même s'en rendre
compte en cuisine notamment quand il
faut calculer la quantité d'ingrédients
à utiliser pour une recette tenez par
exemple le Paris-Brest c'est ma
pâtisserie préférée j'achète souvent
chez mon pâtissier mais il m'arrive de
temps en temps de la confectionner
moi-même alors dans la recette du
Paris-Brest il y a un ingrédient
incontournable le pral en général quand
je prépare un Paris-Brest je le fais
pour
six personnes dans ce cas j'utilise
120 g
de pral
c'est bon maintenant
imaginez que je dois préparer un
Paris-Brest géant pour une classe de 5e
de
31 élèves
quelle quantité de pralin va-t-il me
falloir
que la règle de trois devient très utile
d'abord il faut savoir quelle quantité
de pralin est nécessaire pour une
personne s'il me faut 120 g de pralin
pour 6 pour une personne on divise 120
par 6 résultat
20 g pour confectionner un Paris-Brest
pour 31 élèves il va donc me falloir 31
fois 20 g soit
620 G
de pralin on parle de règles de 3 non
pas parce que cette règle a été mise au
point pendant la guerre de Troie ou dans
la ville de Troie mais tout simplement
parce qu'elle fait intervenir trois
chiffres 6
et 31
je ne pensais pas que les maths
pouvaient ouvrir autant l'appétit
bon joli quand il refait toi baraque
maison
[Musique]
ça devrait suffire voilà des mots du
langage courant vous n'avez d'ailleurs
aucune difficulté à remplacer l'un par
l'autre ce sont des synonymes le
sandwich et 4 routes exactement yes ces
mots ne s'écrivent pas de la même
manière mais ils ont la même
signification dans la langue française
il y en a des milliers et c'est bien
pratique pour éviter les répétitions
mais il faut quand même s'en méfier car
ils ne veulent pas toujours dire
exactement la même chose alors quand les
mots ont le même sens ce sont des
synonymes mais quand ils disent le
contraire ce sont des antonymes un bon
élève un mauvais élève la langue
française compte plus de 20 000
antonymes beau les grands petits je ne
voudrais pas toute la liste les
homonymes quant à eux sont des mots qui
se prononcent ou qui s'écrivent de la
même manière mais ils n'ont pas du tout
la même signification et si c'est leur
prononciation qui est identique on dit
qu'ils sont homoph un pain
pain celui qu'on mange et un pain pays
l'arbre il donne souvent du fil à
retordre aux étrangers lorsqu'ils
apprennent le français ce genre de
phrase par exemple un verre vert va vers
un verre en verre alors l'oreille c'est
un vrai casse-tête et si ce n'est pas la
prononciation mais l'orthographe des
mots qui est identique on dit que les
homonymes sont homographes en d'autres
termes il s'écrivent de la même manière
mais il se prononce différemment par
exemple cet homme est fier doit toujours
s'enfier fier et fier s'écrivent de la
même manière mais ne se prononce pas de
la même façon mais là où ça se complique
c'est quand les homonymes peuvent être à
la fois des homophones et des
homographes il se prononce de la même
façon ils ont exactement la même
orthographe mais ne veulent pas du tout
dire la même chose comme ça ça paraît un
peu compliqué mais c'est très simple
regardez cette phrase le mousse gratte
la mousse sur la coque du bateau ou bien
les poules du couvent couvent leurs œufs
vous me suivez toujours je ne te suis
plus et j'en suis désolé ça marche aussi
pour terminer en beauté un petit mot des
cacahuines il désigne des noms
particulièrement difficiles à porter
certains sont restés célèbres dans
l'histoire comme l'évêque cochon qui a
présidé le procès de Jeanne d'Arc ou
encore le chevalier de la crotte qui
vécu sous le règne de Louis XII mais mon
préféré c'est le nom de ce chimiste
britannique du 19e siècle William prout
en français ça fait prout car lui son
nom est aussi un aptonyme un nom qui lui
va bien puisque c'était un spécialiste
des gaz
les artères les veines les ventricules
les poumons tous ces mots vous
rappellent forcément de vieux souvenirs
de cinquième mais êtes-vous encore
capable de dire quel rôle exact jouait
chacun d'eux dans la circulation du sang
allez on remet un peu d'ordre dans tout
ça la circulation sanguine c'est un
processus très complexe qui permet
d'alimenter nos organes en dioxygène
dioxygène parce que la molécule est
formée de deux atomes d'oxygène mais son
rôle ne s'arrête pas là le sang qui
circule dans les vaisseaux apporte
également les nutriments dont nos
organes ont besoin et les débarrasses de
leurs déchets pour qu'ils fonctionnent
correctement l'organe clé qui est au
cœur de la circulation sanguine celui le
cœur il fonctionne comme une pompe et
propulse le sang grâce à ces deux
ventricules le ventricule droit
propulse leçon dans l'artère pulmonaire
vers les poumons c'est là qu'il se
charge en
et qu'il se débarrasse du dioxyde de
carbone qu'il avait emmagasiné avant de
retourner au cœur par la veine
pulmonaire c'est ce qu'on appelle la
petite circulation le ventricule gauche
lui propulse le sang oxygéné dans la
hotte c'est l'artère principale de notre
organisme elle se ramifie en différentes
artères qui transportent le sang
jusqu'aux organes c'est ce qu'on appelle
la grande circulation ça me rappelle une
expérience rigolote qu'on avait faite en
classe pour prendre conscience que nos
artères transportent bien le sang du
cœur vers les organes
il suffit de placer une balle de tennis
sous l'aisselle comme ceci ensuite on
cherche son pouls au niveau du poignet
et là que se passe-t-il
je sens plus rien
je suis mort c'est normal la balle de
tennis comprime l'artère principale de
votre bras et empêche le sang de
descendre
c'est donc bien la preuve que le sang
circule du cœur
vers la main une fois dans les artères
le sang passe dans les capillaires ce
sont de tout petits vaisseaux qui lui
permettent de pénétrer puis de circuler
dans les organes grâce à leurs parois
très fines le dioxygène contenu dans le
sang peut passer dans les cellules de
tout l'organisme en échange le sang
récupère le dioxyde de carbone et les
autres déchets une fois vidé de son
dioxygène le sang retourne au cœur en
circulant dans les veines il y arrive
par les veines caves la veine cave
supérieure et la veine cave inférieure
et passe dans l'oreillette droite
celle-ci se contracte et envoie le sang
dans le ventricule droit ici puis
direction les poumons afin d'être
oxygéné et débarrasser du dioxyde de
carbone le sang revient ensuite au coeur
par la veine pulmonaire il y arrive dans
l'oreillette gauche puis passe dans le
ventricule gauche avant d'être à nouveau
propulsé dans tout le corps et c'est
reparti pour
[Musique]
quand j'étais en cinquième il y avait un
peu plus de 4 milliards d'êtres humains
sur terre depuis le 15 novembre 2022
nous sommes 8 milliards en un peu plus
de 40 ans ce chiffre a doublé c'est
incroyable d'autant plus incroyable que
pendant des milliers d'années la
croissance de la population mondiale est
restée assez faible et depuis le début
du 19e siècle principalement grâce au
progrès de la médecine elle est
exponentielle en 1800 la terre comptait
environ 950 millions d'habitants en 1950
nous étions 2,5 milliards et aujourd'hui
8 milliards mais comment on fait pour
calculer tout ça je suis sûr que vous
êtes nombreux à vous en souvenir c'était
justement au programme de la cinquième
si je vous dis recensement ça vous parle
il consiste à compter le nombre de
foyers et de personnes qui résident dans
un pays en France c'est un organisme
appelé Insee qui s'en charge je suis sûr
que vous en avez déjà entendu parler
aujourd'hui tous les états rec la
population l'ONU a ensuite pour mission
de rassembler les données afin de
parvenir non pas à un chiffre exact mais
à une estimation car bien sûr il est
impossible de déterminer un chiffre
exact en moyenne il n'est 280 bébés
toutes les minutes et il meurent sans 9
personnes dans le monde j'ai une petite
anecdote à vous raconter à ce sujet qui
date justement de la cinquième en cours
de géo un élève avait demandé à notre
prof si elle savait combien la terre
avait accueilli d'êtres humains depuis
qu'ils existent je vous dis pas sa tête
évidemment elle n'a pas su répondre car
à l'époque personne ne l'avait calculé
mais depuis deux démographes un
Américain et une japonaise on fait le
calcul pour y parvenir ils ont dû
déterminer un point de départ ils n'ont
pas choisi l'apparition des premiers
hominidés il y a trois ou quatre
millions d'années mais le moment où
ceux-ci sont devenus humains ils sont
partis de 190 000 ans avant notre ère à
cette époque nos ancêtres n'étaient que
30 000 à la surface de la planète à
peine de quoi remplir un stade de foot
vous êtes bien assis d'après leurs
calculs
117 milliards d'humains aurait vécu sur
Terre alors la population mondiale va
continuer d'augmenter elle devrait
atteindre 9 milliards d'habitants d'ici
une quinzaine d'années avant de
connaître un pic vers 2080 nous serons
alors environ 10,4 milliards oui vous
avez bien entendu un pic car
contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
croire ce chiffre ne va pas augmenter
advitam eternam d'après les spécialistes
ils devraient stagner jusqu'en 2100
avant de diminuer en raison de la baisse
du taux de fécondité alors que dans les
années 1950 une femme avait en moyenne
cinq enfants au cours de sa vie
aujourd'hui ce tout est descendu à 2,3
il pourrait même passer sous la barre
des deux enfants d'ici la fin du siècle
ce qui fait dire à certains spécialistes
que la population mondiale pourrait non
pas stagner mais baisser de manière
fulgurante d'ici la fin du siècle selon
certaines projections elle pourrait même
être divisée par deux et redescendre à
un peu plus de 4 milliards d'êtres
humains comme quand j'étais en 5e
c'est la récré
alors ce retour en 5e ça vous a plu en
tout cas j'espère que je vous ai permis
de faire resurgir quelques bons
souvenirs de collège si c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à mettre un pouce bleu et
à vous abonner et puis si ce format
continue de vous intéresser bien la
prochaine fois on passe en quatrième
merci pour votre soutien et à très
bientôt chers épicurieuses et épicurieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]